we have this article from vox.com take a
look this from a couple like two weeks
ago sound of Freedom wants to raise
awareness about child trafficking here's
what it what it's really doing oh what
it's really doing I love this let me
just uh do a quick search you know Fox
used to take a look it says Qs that
extremism is at least as dark and
dangerous as the very thing sound of
Freedom wants to combat the crazy thing
about about it is like
that fox made it well Fox made it now
compared to law order SVU it's it's
there's no evil government actors
snatching kids under their arms and like
running out of a pizza restaurant or
anything like that it's just it's a law
enforcement story yeah Disney wanted at
one point right yeah they wanted it it
wasn't extreme they bought it but when
they don't have it anymore it is Extreme
I mean I think what you're doing with
moving to sort of uh creating culture
through the marketplace is really
interesting in some ways it reminds me
of what Matt Gates did saying uh you
know uh Jack Smith the the prosecutor
that's investigating uh Trump he just
was like well you can't have any more
money this isn't worth it this is this
is craziness and I think in some way
really that's ultimately I mean we
talked about a lot with like Public
Square uh the dollar is one way to
leverage power against this institution
so internally Republicans who are in
Congress could theoretically cut off
some of these investigations if they cut
off doj funding and if you guys are able
to say like we know people who are
willing to spend money for entertainment
that they feel represents them and we
make the entertainment then we're able
to circulate this money through people
who have the values and I find that
really interesting but we also learned
like I um we I went to cinemacon this
year Cinema con is where all the studios
come to
talk to the theaters so the the
exhibitors are the theaters and those
are mainstream Americans these are 3 000
plus owners of theaters all across this
country and they're just normal everyday
middle class Heartland Americans and so
the studios come in and at cinemacon
they like it's the most bizarre
experience where you've got these middle
American Theater owners and then you got
these Studios that are coming out of
their bubble and then they're just
trying to sell their content to the
theater owners and so they're they're
kind of like
is there like a cultural
difference they don't really like
there's this there's there's a a a
there's almost uh there's an almost
adversarial adversarial release
relationship but at the same time
they're sitting there whining and dining
the theater is trying to just say okay
we have to work with you I was walking
around with this shirt on this Angel
shirt and they're and I couldn't make it
down the hallway without
five six different theater owners just
stopping and being like hey they pull
out a cross and they're like I'm on your
side
why are you Whispering keep going and
I'm like thank you but but it's it's um
but the amount of support from the
theaters made us realize there's just
this realization as long as we can make
it economically viable
for alternative content to go to the
theaters they will pick
that content
they they'll support it yeah and that's
how the money's made listen to this
theaters July 3rd we had 2 634 theaters
for sound of Freedom July 7th
2852 July 14th
3265. July 21st
2285 July 28th which is coming tomorrow
what day are we it's this Friday
3411. this is like the first movie I've
ever heard of that has expanded the
number of theaters for four Fridays you
might have misread the number I misread
you I thought the third number you read
was a two thousand but it was two it was
3285 it went from three thousand to 65
to 85 to 3 to uh 3411. I've noticed it
like consciously the way it's expanding
too yes it's a caught fire like yeah
psychological thoughts listen to this
stat this is just on uh Reddit thread
sound of Freedom has a shot at 27 State
straight days over 3 million dollars
even end game didn't do that and I'll
believe only a single digit number of
movies have done that somewhere someone
correct me if I'm wrong and everybody's
like a Titanic didn't do it they made it
only to 19 days I'd be interested to
know what the record is that's just a
Reddit thread are tickets more expensive
because inflation obviously has got to
be playing a role sure sure yeah how
much are they now so the average ticket
price is like 11.80 or something like
that yeah and if you go back to like
Passion of the Christ it was somewhere
seven or eight bucks change seven and
change so the sound of Freedom was
number two for the uh July 14th the 20th
yes yes
and we I think we've had four or five
days that we've been number one and um
but um one other thing that's different
is that they've they've re uh factored
all the theaters to do these lounge
chairs I love it that's what we had and
so it's actually going it's changed even
though the ticket price has gone up your
actual number of seats are smaller and
so it's kind of changed the economic
environment yeah Southern frames got
several days uh July 4th it was number
one uh July 10th and 11th was number one
and July 20th it was number one yes yeah
it's amazing and growing yes you
mentioned um crowdfunding because Angel
Studios is a crowdfunding model you see
a hundred thousand Angel Investors that
come in and they vote on what do you
ever find that that causes problems like
chaos within the the structure of the
organism
so far what we've seen is this
incredible
um aptitude for choosing a hit
like the our very first theatrical
release was called his only son there's
this little 250 000 film nobody would
have guessed to take this film to
theaters like you would not this is not
the kind of film you'd take to theaters
it doesn't have a big enough budget
doesn't have any named people first time
director like this film shouldn't have
gone to theaters from Lebanon the main
actress is from Iran and the main and
the boy who plays Isaac Abraham Isaac
he's from Israel like they're just no
namers that are but it did well but we
got the guild score and we're like whoa
whoa and then we put it out there for
crowdfunding and it raised uh 1.25
million in 100 hours and we were
expecting to raise four hundred thousand
dollars in 30 days and we're just like
okay we gotta lean into this because
what the guild is saying and then it hit
number three in the box office against
some huge huge temples but I would
assume this is one of the things that
maybe Hollywood is forgetting is
important like you guys are talking to
actual people who are interested in
movie who would put their money behind
movies and saying what do you want to
see whereas Hollywood has
their own Enclave of people and they're
asking each other it's such an echo
chamber how could you get accurate
feedback on what a good movie would be
yeah yeah you said the guild is the
Guild of the small percentage of the
total fund crowdfunders
anybody who has invested in a previous
project can be a member of The Guild and
that those guys are are the ones who
decide the future of Angel's production
there's about a hundred thousand people
in the angel Guild and the idea here is
is that they replace the Hollywood
Gatekeepers Hollywood's awesome all the
creators the Craftsmen in Hollywood
they're great The Gatekeepers are the
problem and they they they're the ones
who decide like this it has to have this
much uh diversity
figure or this much LBT lgbtq that has
to have this much nudity this many sex
scenes whatever they're the ones just
like deciding these things for the the
content creators and so the filmmakers
are
um they kind of move either direction
but The Gatekeepers are holding holding
the grounds and so the angel Guild is a
replacement of the Hollywood Gatekeepers
and that so we get 60 filmmakers a week
submitting to Angel Studios and then
these The Guild goes through and votes
on that content and about 95 of it fails
and five percent gets through to the
next step yep to the next step when
someone submits they submit oh yeah the
torch yeah so they'll submit like a five
minute short film or or in the case of
sound of Freedom they submitted the
entire film
anecdotally before I show you guys tell
me the torch you call is like this
prototype five minute piece or whatever
full fulfill so technically sound of
Freedom was a torch it's from the Statue
of Liberty's torch I didn't know that
the Statue of Liberty was crowdfunded
yes by French people
yes yeah so Frederick bartaldi couldn't
get any governments to fund the Statue
of Liberty and he wanted had this dream
of creating the biggest piece of art and
we all know artists will try to get
their budget from wherever they can yes
that's right they'll go anywhere to get
their budget but he wanted to create the
biggest piece of art around the biggest
idea in the world then he first tried
the Suez Canal before he visited the
America and and he got shot down he
visits America and he decides this is
the biggest idea America is so he goes
back he gets the president of the United
States to say I think that's a great
idea takes back a letter because the
president didn't offer him any money I
mean even the Washington Monument was
crowdfunded I don't know if you knew
that but the um because the government
wouldn't pay for stuff like that back
then and they have times have changed
they had principles
um so so they they he goes back to to
France and he raises just enough money
to build the torch and a hand and he
sets it up in the Parks and he takes
people up in the top of the torch and he
takes pit black and white pictures of
him there's a whole bunch of them online
you can see this black and white
pictures of this torch and he raised 14
million dollars in today's money over a
decade he'd give out little pins yeah
little things it was the first
Kickstarter campaign yes first
crowdfunding campaign yeah and he and he
spends a decade and he builds it so we
just modeled the entire brand
of our company is we have torches which
are the the filmmakers even like every
year we do what are called the torch
Awards where we actually give away a a
copper replica of the torch of the
Statue of Liberty to filmmakers so
there's um yeah we the idea is around
the original crowdfunding campaign I
think a lot of the problems in today's
society can be solved with crowdfunding
a lot of like roads you really worry
about the roads don't wait for the
government you know set up but we just
need maybe some Organization for it like
an app or something where you can like
locally send some some tips yeah yeah
and what what happens as soon as you
engage the crowd
like when we raise the smartest money we
can raise for advertising is from the
crowd because everybody comes in they
can do they maybe throw 50 bucks at it
or 20 bucks or whatever and then they go
out and they bring it drag all their
neighbors into the theaters so if you
get seven thousand ten thousand people
crowdfunding a project
you've got 10 000 an army of 10 000
people out dragging everybody they know
into those theaters to try to make that
movie profitable of the hundred thousand
Angel Investors that you currently have
uh do they all invest in every movie no
no they don't all invest every single
movie we bring on a giant chunk of new
people over half how do people sign up
to invest
invest.angel.com is where
um the the different projects go up for
to raise money there's a link there at
angel.com yeah is it the same way for
writers and stuff that want to submit
like as if you need more another
thousand submissions so so we're not
currently set up to
um to take scripts uh we only can take
torches like only like projects that
show a vision for what you're trying to
create
um but um there's also a link on there
for the angel accelerator fund and they
they have they actually
um
they partner with some filmmakers to
help create torches what's it called the
angel accelerate accelerator fund and
they'll they'll help people that don't
have money but have a great idea or like
a great really great they're gonna have
to bring their own money like they match
torch like if a torch costs 100 Grand
they might put up 50 and then the torch
would be then the the filmmaker would
have to bring 50.
let's talk about uh winning the culture
War so I think one of the reasons sound
of freedom is so important is uh making
130 30 million dollars several days at
number one proving that outside as you
mentioned The Gatekeepers there is a
path towards success yes younger people
need to be able to look at the stuff
that we're creating and say there is
another way to succeed you don't have to
go through the corrupt machine thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time